there's a different method of talking
about coins you know you could you can
imagine somebody spinning a coin on its
edge and seeing does it come up heads or
tails and if you're me you could ask
well you know what are the odds if a
coin is spun on its edge what are the
odds it comes up heads or tails now
there's a right answer to that question
you don't know because you don't know
magicians have coins which are slightly
shaved and you can't feel it you can't
see it but the coin always comes up
tails when it's spun on its edge it has
to do in a very delicate way where the
center of gravity of the coin is
determining that is a completely
different physics task math task we have
done it experimentally it's not so easy
to do the math of it and experimentally
coins are quite biased and that's an
easy experiment to do you can get a
class of kids and I've done it with a
class of a hundred students a given coin
has its own bias when spun on the edge
but that bias fluctuates from coin to
coin and there it's easy to find coins
which are 80% tails just the slightly
you know bevel pennies and nickels coins
American coins which have unbelled edges
this coin has a serrated edge coins
which have unser ated edges tend to be
more biased and it so that you know if
you just happen to have one in your
pocket well you know who pays for the
drinks right or whatever I'm going to
combine those two ideas if I asked you
before this interview which do you think
is fair a coin caught in the hand or a
coin allowed to drop on to the table we
can do that a few times so you can you
know catch it try to catch it now a coin
allowed to do that
well first of all most people have asked
which is fairer just think this guy's
nuts that question doesn't make sense
you know they're both kind of pretty
fair but if pressed people when pushed
seem to think that a coin dropping on
the floor is fairer and I'd like to
suggest that when why the people guess
that that when somebody catches a coin
in their hand there's a hand there and
it might be that you can adjust your
hand or do something
let's rule that out okay you're just
flipping coins for yourself you're not
trying to cheat anybody if you flip a
coin this way or if you flip a coin and
let it land on the floor does it make
any sense to talk about is one fairer
than the other but when a coin hits the
ground because I watch them in a few
heads your Gambhir we could watch them
together before it dies often it spins
around on its edge before dying and some
of that edge bias comes in and so
there's a real sense in which coins
landing on the floor a less fair than
coins caught in the air well there's
something to think about
fast it was traveling if say in feet per
second and if you knew how many times a
second it was turning over Newton tells
you if you know the speed how long it
takes to come down and if you know how
fast it's turning you know whether it'll
come up heads or tails